now cones and pyramids they have a
similar shape and they have a similar
formula for finding the surface area so
whenever possible I like to group
formulas together just to make it easier
to memorize and I think you'll find that
easier too so let's look at the formula
the surface area of course is the outer
surface of the object all surfaces and
you can see it's the area of the base so
the capital B means the area of the
bottom the base so in this case it's
going to be a square for this pyramid
although it could be a triangular
pyramid or any type of pyramid but it'd
be the area of the base here in this
cone it's going to be a circle so you're
gonna find the area of the base using
those formulas for that particular shape
and then you're gonna do one half the
perimeter of the base times L which is
the slant height now the slant heights
like the like the leaning height like
this angle height we don't want the
overall height we use that when we
calculate the volume we're using the
leaning or slant height so it's this one
here or this one here okay now in the
pyramid you don't want to use this edge
this is called the lateral edge okay we
want actually the height of the triangle
so that would be this height right here
so what I've done with the pyramid in
this first example is I've I basically
peeled it like a banana right so peeled
it back okay and laid it flat they call
that a net and what you have is you've
got a square here on the bottom and four
triangles okay so if you wanted to you
could just find the area of the square
and the area of one of these triangles
multiply that by four add everything
together and you got it but what the
formula does is it doesn't a little bit
more efficient way for you so I'll show
you how that works so the area of the
base here let's write down the formula
it's going to be B plus 1/2 PL the base
is a square so 6 times 6 is 36 plus 1/2
now the perimeter of the base that's the
distance all the way around that's going
to be 6 times 4 you can see that there
so it's 24 and then the slant height the
leaning height in this case is 5 ok like
the leaning the Leaning Tower of Pisa
right ok so this is 1/2 times 24 is 12
times 5 is 60 plus 36 is 96 units
squared ok because it's area where it's
two-dimensional we're just covering it
up with a little one-by-one
squares okay now for the cylinder its
I'm sorry for the cone it's a little bit
different because you can go ahead and
draw the circular base but it's a little
bit tricky to you know draw the sides
okay there's a lateral area if you try
to unfold it it doesn't fold flat like
the pyramid I just kind of you know
guess that what that would look like
it's hard to really you know unfold this
okay so it's still the same formula
though it's the area of the base plus
1/2 PL now let's break this down so the
base is a circle so what's the formula
of the area of a circle it's PI R
squared right so it's going to be pi
times 5 squared K cos the radius is 5
plus 1/2 the perimeter of the base so
the perimeter of the base is just
another way of saying the circumference
and what's the formula for circumference
well it's 2 pi R or you could say pi
times diameter and you'll notice that
the 1/2 and the 2 they cancel each other
out because half of 2 is 1 and so what
we're left with here is pi times R times
L so in some books you'll see 4 cones PI
R square plus PI RL okay but I've just
written it this way so you have less
formulas to memorize ok area the base
plus 1/2 PL and so now we've got PI
times the radius which is 5 and the
slant height this angled height which is
13 okay so if we simplify this we get 5
squared is 25 times pi plus 5 times 13
which is 65 pi if we add those together
we get 90 PI units square